hello everyone my name is Amy metha and
[Applause]
and I'm the director of product design
at Evernote so I'm the last speaker here
this evening and feel really honored to
be here so today I want to ask you guys
to take a journey with me a journey into
the past where I had three sort of
significant turning points in my life
these turning points were points that
helped me to get deeper in my own sense
of identity and helped me to understand
who I was on deeper and deeper levels
the first one was when I realized that I
was an American girl in an Indian family
the second one was when I realized that
I was a minority in America and the
third one was when I found a purposeful
community like-minded individuals so as
we take this journey I want you to know
that for me the journey was not linear
it was actually much more like a maze
twists and turns darkness and lightness
it was a mixture of all of these things
and the maze was circular in nature
where there was a beginning a discrete
middle where the realization would take
place and a retracing of the steps back
to the beginning again and what we call
this maze is a labyrinth so these three
journeys helped me to not only
understand my own identity more deeply
but they served as a compass to help me
navigate life experiences so the very
first one I was born to Indian parents
in Boulder Colorado and we used to go
back every summer to India and as I got
older I remember this time
where we went to my uncle's house my dad
was one of sixteen brothers and sisters
and he remembered that we were going
there for dinner in Bombay and my
brother and father were escorted into
the living room to have the intellectual
conversation and my sister mother and I
were gently escorted into the kitchen to
make sure that the food was prepared for
the men to eat so as I was helping to
roll the rotis and make sure that the
food was all hot I was really angry
inside I thought why did they get a B in
the living room having the intellectual
conversation and I have to make the
dinner in the kitchen so we served them
the food that evening and we made sure
they had enough to eat and we cleared
the table and we basically went back to
the kitchen and sat on the floor and ate
on the floor because that's what you did
in this particular family so at a very
young age I thought if this is what it
means to be Indian I don't want any part
of it no thank you
you know I would I want to be American I
want the image I want to live the
American dream I want freedom I want
equality a few years later when I was in
Colorado and yet again my mom was like
we got to make dinner and you know your
dad and brother have to eat and we were
making dinner and doing the dishes and I
was just got really angry I kind of
threw a fit and I got my sister who's
younger who's here in the audience right
now and we went downstairs and I said
let's make these signs so he wrote out
these signs and we wrote on them let
Inquilab so we went around the
house and we added these little sticks
to the bottom of the sign and we went
around the house and we picketed and we
said me and frightened her my younger
sister right behind me lud uncle of
blood uncle of blood inqalab
which means for those of you that don't
know Hindi women's revolution
so I was 11 years old and my sister was
9 and I realized it wasn't about being
Indian or being American that I was
resisting it was being a girl growing
into a woman in a patriarchal structure
in a patriarchal system and all women
and all people actually are part of this
patriarchy and so what I was resisting
was patriarchy and what I did about this
was decide not to buy into it I decided
that I was going to be as good as any
man or better I was going to succeed at
all costs I was going to be
self-sufficient and I was going to make
my way through life and I decided that
patriarchy was not going to get the best
of me
so the second turning point that I went
through was 9/11 in 2001 it's when the
twin towers went down in New York
remember us working in the corporate
world I was in Palo Alto I was in my
apartment and I saw on the TV the towers
go down and I remember being so scared
I'd never been so scared in my entire
life and I remember going to the closet
looking for the biggest blanket that I
could find to try to wrap around me to
feel safe but nothing was going to make
me feel safe nothing was going to make
anyone any of us still safe from
something like that so the next day I
got a call from a friend who had told me
a very good friend of ours from school
happened to be working in the towers
that day and he passed away he died and
so I couldn't leave my apartment for a
couple days I was so afraid to just go
outside I was so afraid to face the
world if this was what the world was
like at this time and I remember finally
getting the courage and got on my
jogging shoes and I jogged from my
apartment to Molly stones a small
grocery store nearby and when I got to
the grocery store and I got to the doors
and I was about to walk in an older
white man across the parking lot was
looking at me with this hateful look and
he started to scream out at me and he
said why don't you go back to the
country you came from we don't need you
terrorizing us here in America and at
this moment I just didn't even know what
to say
I was already devastated from everything
that had happened I didn't respond I
didn't know how to respond I walked into
the grocery store and I started walking
down the aisles and I just started
crying and crying and crying and I kept
thinking but I am in my country I am
American America is a melting pot this
is my country too
but what I realized there was these were
deep deep forms of racism that I felt
not only that day but I think this was
the day I truly acknowledged it I think
I've experienced racism as many people
of color and other people have
throughout my life but what I realized
was that I wasn't going to let this get
the best of me either as I continued to
walk through the labyrinth and take
twists and turns I was going to be
better than this I was going to be
resilient I was not going to buy into
small minds I was not going to let him
or anyone else take my power away so the
third turning point that I experienced
was when I went back to grad school I
went to Stanford and I got my master's
in education in learning design and
technology and I loved it I loved the
program I loved every book I was reading
as the biggest nerd in the class I sat
in the front row
I got strata is that year but I met
people in this program but cared about
the same things I did making a
humanitarian difference thinking about
educational technology
and ways that we could be instruments to
serve to something greater and so this
tried this community of people that I
met during this program were just like
me
I found identity in them but it was
because we had the same purpose we had
the same goals we wanted to make that
difference in the same way and so I
started to finally find a sense of
identity and yet all of these friends
who are still lifelong friends are from
every culture around the world every
race around the world and very different
mindsets yet a common goal so today I
finally feel like I have been able to
understand accept and embrace what it
means to be Indian American my identity
as an Indian American and as a woman who
will not let anyone steal her power as
you guys think about your lives I just
want you to take a second and close your
eyes think about the labyrinths of your
lives where are you right now in your
journey are you running into mentors and
teachers and friends or are you learning
in running into tricksters and monsters
and people that want to steal your power
the only advice I can give around this
is if you keep on going and you
persevere and you don't let racism or or
patriarchy or different forms of
oppression get the best of you you can
continue to find deeper levels of
yourself so what I wish for today and as
you can see you heard the journey and
the journeys of many other women here
tonight is that we as women can come
together we can come together as a
community we can come together with
different perspectives and yet a
commonality in terms of experiencing
different forms
of oppression we can come together as a
coalition to support one another
especially today especially in these
times thank you
[Applause]